look look billboard high 100 number one
no wait hold on hold on hold on hold on
now from the top make it
drop that's some wet and cushion cardi b
can't contain her excitement
as she celebrates her and megan the
stallion single [ __ ]
hitting number one hold on hold on hold
on
hold on
rob debuts 93 million u.s streams the
most fun song in opening week in history
that's right the single also made
history
surpassing ariana grande's hit seven
rings
which had 85.3 million streams
during its first week swap's
history-making stride
doesn't end there it's also the first
female rap collaboration
in history to debut at number one and i
want to say thank you so much
making the styling like i hope you are
just as happy as i am
but i just want later on i'm gonna give
you a testimony because when i tell you
when jesus says
nobody can say no nobody
cardi is celebrating these milestones in
a few different ways
first by sending meg a very special
and expensive gift
i know you [ __ ] love
girl [ __ ]
nothing the rapper went the extra mile
with the hermes birkin bag
by adding a custom painting inspired by
the [ __ ] music video
and meg's houston roots nothing
[Applause]
on the bottom of the bag the savage
rapper showed off a sweet message from
cardi
saying quote thank you meg really
appreciate you
meg captioned the video in part quote
thank you friend
omg i can't believe you i wonder what
i'm gonna get her
at i am cardi b
cardi also celebrated her latest success
with her husband offset
and their two-year-old baby girl culture
this is what i do it for
to make my family practice she took to
instagram live shortly after the news of
wap hitting number
one to have a sweet sing-along to how
far i'll go
from disney's moana where's my part my
part coming my parkour
what is wrong with me
we've watched cardi's career explode
after her breakout hit
bodak yellow in 2017.
[Music]
and now [ __ ] is cardi b's fourth hot 100
number one and megan the stallion second
the hit song has received some criticism
over its sex-positive lyrics
but according to cardi the message of
the song is really about women
supporting women people expect you to
act like a disney
channel star and it's that i'm not that
you know sometimes i'm very sexual
sometimes i say naughty things and it's
like i don't want to like pause myself
from doing what i want to do because i'm
like this
role model that's just not me
i'm a grown woman too you know so as a
grown woman i feel like i should do
and say what i want
you